I took a glyphosate test, since you found it to be a possible cause when you did belly
in last cheek.
So I'm going to say that the result was 1.5, which looks to be in the 50th percentile.
Is this a very bad score?
Yeah, I did look at your test.
Is it a bad score?
There isn't any good score when it comes to glyphosates.
Let's just leave it at that.
How much do you think this could contribute to my breast cancer?
Well, remember, so what your score is today, doesn't mean that's what your score was four
years ago when the kids started growing.
Why didn't you diagnose two years ago?
Yeah, I said that right.
Your kids started growing long before you were diagnosed.
So your score might have been much higher than you've got a lot of detox work up to this
point and then you just get the test done your score might have been way worse even six
months ago.
When you took the cheek swab, you had already suggested increasing my cleartoxets every
per day.
That on kale support at HMET by during the active from cell core.
I'm still doing coffee at a memory day and you graduated to the day, time and highest quality
beta can afford.
I don't think there's anything else you have to do based upon the results of those test.